[Music]
Morgan wallen's son was rushed to the ER
after being attacked by a dog on Sunday
the country stars X KT Smith took to her
Instagram stories to share the
heartbreaking news that their
two-year-old son Indigo had been bit in
the face by her rescue dog Legend
yesterday he
bit Indigo and um in the face and had to
have stitches indigo is okay his scar
will be minimum he did have stitches but
she'll be okay KT further explained that
she adopted her dog at a rescue just
over a year ago she's now trying to find
something Humane to do with Legend as
she's not willing to put the dog down
following the attack
what the world tells you to do is to put
the dog down because they are
aggressive
and
I've gone back and forth with that and I
knew in my heart that he does not
deserve that because he is wonderful and
could do really great with a family that
doesn't have small children and um
maybe just has like a lot of land I'm
getting Indigo back home tomorrow and he
has to be gone by then and I cannot I
can't put him down either he doesn't
like I said he doesn't deserve that he
deserves the life of love and just
to be who he is as a dog which is
loving and
he's calm and he's such a good dog and
he just wants love and he hasn't shown
any bit of aggression before that at all
um
he's great with other dogs but I'm
asking that if anyone is in the
Nashville area
or surrounding and is able to
give him a home today I know that's a
huge ask
um please
send me a text now Katie later shared an
update announcing that she did find a
home for legend with the sweetest family
adding that he will be living out his
full potential and best life on a farm I
couldn't have asked for a better family
for him to be loved on by and they're
East Tennessean so we can visit anytime
we need to